when you get seizures like sometimes
it's you lock out right away yeah
sometimes it's like like this and you
kind of have like this cerebral palsy
moment like half your face shuts down
and you just see this helplessness in
their eye and they come and then they
start foaming after nothing oh my God so
there's there's times he goes like this
he trips and falls like this and I'm
like taika oh [__] I'm like are you okay
I turn around he goes
I'm like you mother
[__]
[Music]
do you have an Oculus VR oh I do have an
Oculus vrag
master
I see why you're married what else do
you have Anthony that was good how badly
how badly did you want it when you uh
saw that it was like a thing not badly
um
some things I get but I don't badly want
you're just boggling like that you could
just buy things that you don't really
give a [__] about it was an investment
seal through to the garbage I took a
loan out together like I thought it was
a massager turns out it's [__] BR do
you even love Nina are you just married
because
[Laughter]
good questions by the way what's article
about there's no article it's just
wondering what gate question though what
game do you like on there on the Oculus
they all actually aren't that good
but the most fun one that you end up
having with is it the music yeah beat
saber yeah yeah yeah is that like a band
no it's like a DDR but like with [__]
you're looking at like you have like
lightsabers and then you're just like
hitting the directional colored boxes
that are flying towards you yeah and
then you sometimes have to like Dodge
like these giant like orange walls and
stuff like that while like slicing [__]
so it's really fun to do but if you're
by yourself it's not like I want to play
Beat saver by myself it's more of like a
party trick when it's like hooked up to
the TV you know what I mean stuff like
that because if you put on by yourself
do you guys feel like a loser like what
the [__] I used to play Guitar Hero by
myself all the time I love guitar Heroes
too that's different like that actually
you're not also like giving yourself
this giant headache and then like all
the music and everything's on the TV
whereas this thing it's like it's just
right here okay if you ever play Guitar
Hero after play playing Guitar Hero look
up at the ceiling it moves yeah
and you can play it you're like you're
on mushrooms
well sleep playing Guitar Hero why it
reminds me so bad in it well yeah I love
it I'd always hear those sucks
whenever you hit the wrong note and then
like you hear the like okay and I'm like
oh [__] it's the worst but just like the
the stream of the lines it's hypnotizing
hypnotizing I'm just like you and to
sleep yeah I'll fall asleep dude also
you wake up to the crowd booing you
Van Halen dude I like that that the VR
thing makes you feel like a loser that's
a tagline becomes a loser well some
things people are playing VR they look
like pretty losers yeah some things it's
almost
yeah because some things you put on it's
like putting on the uniform of like I
have no friends whoa that's [__] up I
played the VR dude or maybe like you're
you're maybe like you're like you're
like Mike song and you see Anthony doing
this you're like I don't want to be this
friend anymore
honestly the more you guys talk about
Anthony
the less I want to be his friend I'm
telling you sick she's bulldozed hey I
want to be your friend Aunt so oh [__]
man I'm gonna put on my yard
we can play together I know that Anthony
was pro-cancer too and I was like
he's a big cancer football bro what's up
[__]
ain't no amateur [__] hair dude can I
borrow your Oculus you're not gonna use
it
you want to be not for porn damn it
is the best part about it we've talked
about it here before you've actually
watched it you can watch porn oh yeah
yeah
you don't watch it you experience it oh
[__]
floors
let's say you were 10 years old do you
think you would love the Oculus more
yeah yeah for sure yeah oh [__] I don't
think it's crazy because you're
transporting into another world
so there's um kid in Milwaukee 10 years
old oh [__] oh there's an article yeah
his um his mom because I supported
murder or some [__] watch his mom
refused to buy her 10 year old the
Oculus oh I know this story oh no oh you
do
so what did he do that's an Oculus
Community we're really familiar about
this do you guys want to guess
you go ahead he killed her mom oh that's
the one took a credit card another one
would be like
he just made a cardboard Oculus and
pretended oh that's good he made his own
that's what a Japanese kid would know
it's all about that joke
that's breaking news he had an
imagination
washer box and he made a spaceship this
just in a kid did some kid [__] but down
that Ukraine news hang on so this um kid
he took his mom's gun from a room and
killed her Jesus Christ but the crazy
thing the crazy thing is that it's not
it's not just that he wanted isolation
shot and I only said that because I
remember when I was 10. I had I was so
pissed that I had the feeling
and I would I would never kill my mom I
haven't she's been alive you haven't I
wouldn't for the record track record is
allegedly allegedly good at not killing
my mom so far I thought it was normal to
have those feelings but I had those
feelings like I had those feelings of
like man it would be pretty sick if like
Mom came home one day and parked in the
garage and the garage door wouldn't help
open and the car exhaust just flooded
and she just peacefully wet you're smart
you're [__] sick and I remember
having those kind of thoughts at 10.
from her not wanting to buy you
something no no just like I didn't like
the way I was being raped so I was the
opposite I was like what if my dad came
home he just saw me dead on the floor
like
it's because my dad didn't love me I
should have got the Oculus oh you'd be
so mad if I was just dead on the floor
it's like the Christmas story bit where
the parents like oh he's like I'm so
sick because you made me eat soap yeah
yeah that's exactly I'm an idiot parent
I wrote full like full on chapters in my
diary about like how I'll be like yeah
and then he and then he then he'd love
me you know it's a really sad a really
sad sight thing uh I accidentally did
that
um totally unintentionally yeah but I
lived that exact thing because my mom me
and my mom got into like a fight I was
like a teenager and then um I decided to
like wash my hair out so I like put the
um the tub like I turned the the tub
faucet on and I was just like kneeling
next to it with my head under the thing
and I was just waiting for it to wash
out and then my mom came home later and
she walked in and she thought that I
drowned myself oh my God and all I
didn't even know she was there and all I
heard was she was standing above because
I was just like waiting like this oh
[__] and then my mom I just heard her go
all right
and I felt a heartbreaking though yes
dude dude that made my heart sink right
why was the saddest good thing and I
looked up and went what and then she was
like she had like tears in her eyes and
I was like holy [__] dude oh my God I
really killed myself
I was like that's [__] funny so dark
that's so dark yeah and then does she
have a Filipino accent yeah of course a
great one one of the best taika's a
[__] right this [__]
gets seizures and [__] and he knows it
he knows it he [__] knows it and he
knows he gets so worried about it so
sometimes he will like trip and fall
when you get seizures like sometimes
it's you lock out right away yeah
sometimes it's like like this and you
kind of have like this cerebral palsy
moment like half your face shuts down
and you just see this helplessness in
their eye and they come and then they
start foaming after nothing oh my God so
there's there's times he goes like this
he trips and falls like this and I'm
like taika oh [__] I'm like are you okay
I turn around he goes
I'm like you mother
no we're done
okay so does this kid like this is [__]
this kid executes his mother right yeah
when the cops show up is this kid
[__] sitting there with a gun and
he's sitting in a chair and he's got a
little thing of scotch and he's like
which one of you he's taking me get a
[__] Oculus
[Laughter]
the sad thing is it's even it's even
weirder uh he's the kid is such a clear
[__] sociopath this is what actually
happens so see that's what I
yeah so here's how he does it he asked
his mom for Oculus he said no right
um so yeah he shoots or whatever but um
the way they found out is that
um the next day
the ant was like uh what happened and he
was like oh it was an accident I found
her gun I started playing with it this
10 year old kid he said he was
controlling it around and it shot and it
and it hit her and it was an accident so
that's why they told the cops it was an
accident whatever but then the aunt
noticed on the mom's phone that he had
ordered an Oculus on Amazon after he
killed it the day after oh yeah so she
was like why did you do that and and
then he goes oh it was because she
wouldn't buy it for me and then and then
he confesses it and goes actually here's
here's what I really did I pointed it at
her she said stop and then I just shot
her
and then she noticed that he wasn't
crying had no remorse whatsoever
he's just not [__] up it's so scary do
they always know that he was kind of off
I'm sure they did yeah a kid like that's
got to have some kind of like signals
right where they're just like breaking
heads off canaries and [__] there's
nothing wrong with this why the [__] he
got canaries
first yeah that's how they start but
does he know there's no works yeah
he's like I don't play [__] beat
saber well they did put this child to
work in a coal mine that's kind of
against the law
pray to God there's good games for this
thing he will do it again no but that
that's the craziest [__] is that he
really just yeah they know no sense of
like oh I feel bad for what I did did he
get to play the Oculus though
how did
he said it's not that great yeah he's
actually not that good it was gonna be
worth my mom
he's like the reason I want one is
because I'm finished with this reality
[Music]
thank you